to me like i i izakayas is like my
number one kind of drinking
establishment that i enjoy throughout
the world i mean
anyways the easiest it's the chillest
it's the chillest you know you always
it's always nice all foreigners love it
because it's so easy you press the
little button
sometimes it's all you control because
you don't have to order at the bar you
never have to order them never
never would have i will say that is 100
times better than the uk
you all order all your food and drinks
from a tablet there's no pressure to get
water at the bar and they just bring it
to you
there is one of my favorite izakayas i
go to a lot with my
other friends is uh it's one in
ikabukuro uh i don't know what it's
called anymore it used to be called
kobayashi's i think i took you guys
there i don't remember
but basically it's it's like it's uh on
the west side
of ikebukuro and it's underground and
like it's like it's exactly like in
izakaya
so it has like food and everything but
you pour your own drinks
oh yeah i think i've been to that one as
well and there's like a huge
like tub like it's like a [ __ ] barrel
full of miso shooter
like miso soup and it's just all you can
drink miso soup as well it's the best
[ __ ] thing ever because it's just
like because miso soup is like
the ultimate hangover drink in my
opinion yeah because
like another thing i want to talk about
when it comes to japanese drinking
culture
is nomihoudai oh
anytime someone from england or like or
like
america or someone comes here and they
see
how many like they learn about the all
you can drink culture yeah yeah yeah
it's like
boys i'm i'm moving here i'm coming out
every night
every australian i've taken to a normie
holiday has always either been like
so is there like a drink limit or
they're like
oh it's only for like 10 minutes right
like it's like happy hour right it's
like no you can do it for as long as you
want they're just like
how are they how much is like a typical
nominee
1500 for 30 minutes is it no no no no no
it's cheaper than that you go either
either it's like i've seen like 2 000
yen for two hours yeah i think it's it's
about so it's about 20 bucks for two
hours
of all your computers where you go but
generally it's around that price
around that price and compared to like
everywhere you see in
england and everything that's like a
massively good deal
exactly it's like why would you not like
even if you can't drink that much right
yeah yeah
why would you not take that even if
you'd like
i'm at like a brisk pace yeah it's still
a good value for money yeah because even
like
say like you know it's like 500 yen for
a beer yeah
even if you drink four beers in the two
hours you're still getting your money's
worth yeah
yeah so it's like every time i'm just
like i don't really feel like drinking
that much
well let's go not me hold on i i
remember
because obviously when you move here you
kind of like stop wanting all you can
drink because you're like it wears off
yeah yeah well the first few times i
visited here i remember thinking like
treating it like an olympic event i'm
like
right how many can i do in the gym no
because because that's that's what it
would be like if there wasn't all you
can drink in england right well it would
be yeah that's how we think because
that's how we're wired you're like yeah
you're like 80 speed running
i was like i was like get the clock
ready
time time i remember i literally had
this dilemma i was like
i was drinking a beer and the first one
i smashed it back no problem yeah yeah
that was easy
second beer i was like [ __ ] i'm i'm two
seconds off pace
like i remember i i actually remember
being like i'm one minute off the pace
actually i'm so good
i was like exactly the same you're like
if how many
how many beers do i need to drink to
make this worth in how many can i go
over yeah you're like calculating this
in your hair to be like okay if i drink
one beer every five to ten minutes then
like i can smash this many beers and i'd
be like
earning back this amount of money you
know what i mean yeah
we're trying to get like stalks this is
okay because we
i remember this we i first came here as
a tourist we visited a bar that had 200
yen
beers yeah i thought okay that's my new
baseline for all you can drink
i need to make sure i get more of my
money
i need to make sure it's more better
value than 200 yen a beer
so i think we went to one that was like
2 000 yen for two hours and i was like
okay in my head i'm working it out i'm
like okay yeah that's ten beers
i need to get at least ten beers yeah so
i was like all right i gotta get 11.
just to just to get an under so i feel
like this was worth coming to
and i remember i was in so much [ __ ]
pain on like the ninth beer
yeah that i got because we were eating
as well yeah yeah my stomach was like
because i think it was like eight beers
in where i was like i don't know if i
forgot to tell you but you can get other
drinks too like it's not it doesn't have
to be just
i knew that getting all you can drink
like spirits was playing with fire oh
yeah and i would i would have been like
on the floor
so i'm like no i'll stick with beer
because beer is like the natural piece
now i'm going to take you guys to the 50
yen beer place because there's not an
oil you can drink but it's 50 i mean
it's 50 yen so it might as well be all
you can yeah right
because i i feel like that's just the
difference in mindset between anyone
from like the west
people in japan right because when
anyone in the west comes over and hears
all you can drink or all you can eat
it's it's a it's the same mindset where
you're just like
i've got i've got to [ __ ] speed run
this i'm gonna optimize this what is the
optimal speed run strats
all you can drink and japanese people
are just like you know we just drink
however much we feel like
it's just like the pressure of not
having to know how much i'm gonna yeah
because i think it works on like the
trust system yeah because i remember
we trust you not to be a [ __ ]
alcoholic because
that's why this would never work in any
other country but like japan
yeah because i remember i went to like
uh i went to this uh kind of like no it
wasn't a wine bar what's like the place
that they make wine what's that called
winery that's that's the place so i went
to this winery with sydney
um just outside of tokyo um and they
basically had a seller
of about like a thousand different wines
right and
basically you could you could sample as
much as you as much as you like
for 10 bucks 10 bucks you had a seller
of a thousand that's like
that's gonna be some willy wonka test
it's like if you actually go
greedy you're gonna like get the kill
you're going into the water you're going
you know
you can drink as much of it as you want
for ten bucks okay so you can sample as
much of it so every every
sample every british people don't sound
true that's exactly the point that's
exactly the point i'm trying to make so
uh so me and sydney went in being like
the exact same mindset where it's like
there must be a catch there must be a
catch
this can't
and they give us like this little cup
right it's like the super small cup
uh where you can pour like i'd say a
third of a glass of wine into it okay
and these japanese people were just
pouring like
one little drop like two little drops
now just like just like letting it
letting the drop like sit in their
tongue yeah yeah and then we were just
like
but we can draw we can pour however much
we want rice
sorry in sydney like because that's
that's the thing
it's based on the trust system yeah yeah
but you know if
you want to but but if you want to you
can just pour however much you want for
as many wines as you want
and no one's going to stop you right so
there's something there's something
similar to that that i saw in uh
oh [ __ ] where was it i think it was in
nagano when i went for a trip it was
like a sponsored trip and at the station
because nagano is kind of known for its
sake yeah there was exactly the same
thing it was like
50 to like 100 like barrels of all sorts
of different sake and it's like yeah
again like it was like one of everything
yeah it was like yeah it was like a
thousand yen for like all you can test
oh you can test oh you can it's not all
you can drink it's all you can test yeah
yeah
all you can sample and i'm just like
hell yeah
but but there's nothing stopping you
from sampling as much as you're like
right
i was like 20 and i was like i'm only a
fifth of the way through this i'm about
to [ __ ] like imagine if you can ask
for a free sample but there's no one
stopping you from asking for unlimited
free stuff
you get unlimited free samples that's
basically the mindset
so it's so like we're here as a
westerner thinking we got the [ __ ]
cheat code to this yeah so we can just
like it's like bottomless fries but if
you can go up and get your own fries
right
it's like it's like having a buff in
this country it's like being british
alcohol it's like oh [ __ ] yeah